the Duggars back on TV CLC canceled 19  Kids and Counting following Josh  Duggar's molestation scandal seven  months ago but source tells ET the  family is still mean in their Arkansas  town once again and that they have been  filming quote for a few months now  another source tells ed the family is  still under contract with TLC and that  the network is especially interested in  the Duggar girls stories quote I'm sure  there will be more girls cordeen soon in  December TLC air to three-part special  that focused on Jill and Jessa Josh  Duggar is still in rehab and there's no  word on whether he'll be seen on TLC  again but we're told his wife anna is  still living with the family josh was my  first love he's my one and only in  December a source told ET that Josh and  Anna spent the holidays apart he checked  into a faith-based rehab center in  August